C'est l'histoire d'un conflit
d'une grande violence
et dont personne ne voit la fin.
L'histoire d'une haine
entre deux peuples
qui se disputent
la même terre depuis des décennies.
Attentats suicides.
Raids aériens.
Guérilla urbaine.
Chaque jour, la poudrière
du Proche-Orient menace la paix.
Ce conflit que plus personne ne comprend,
a commencé il y a un siècle.
C'est cette histoire
que nous allons vous raconter.
Pourquoi quelques Juifs
ont-ils décidé de retourner en Israël,
l'ancien royaume de Judée,
après 2 000 ans d'exil ?
Pourquoi ont-ils combattu
les troupes coloniales britanniques ?
Comment se sont-ils imposés
face aux Arabes de Palestine ?
Quelques années
seulement après avoir subi
l'un des plus grands traumatismes
que le monde ait connu, le nazisme.
Pendant des années,
des passionnés
de cinéma ont filmé leurs aventures.
Des Juifs.
Des Arabes.
Leurs films
témoignent de la violence,
mais aussi
de leur vie quotidienne,
de leurs espoirs
et de leurs rêves.
Nous avons retrouvé
ces films amateurs pour vous.
Avec Bärbel et Ella Weiler,
deux petites
juives allemandes
qui ont échappé de justesse avec
leurs parents aux persécutions nazies..
Avec la famille Katz,
ces Juifs d'Europe de l'Est
qui ont enduré le génocide
avant de rejoindre
clandestinement l'État d'Israël.
Avec les Arens,
des militants sionistes.
Nous allons vous raconter la tragédie
et l'odyssée du peuple juif au XXᵉ siècle.
Nous serons aussi
avec la famille Saïd,
des Arabes
de Jérusalem.
Avec les Kouri
dans la ville de Jaffa,
ainsi que plusieurs acteurs
du drame palestinien.
Nous les suivrons
dans leur révolte
et sur les routes de l'exil.
De l'arrivée d'Hitler
au pouvoir en 1933
à la création
de l'État d'Israël en 1948,
retour sur ces 15 années cruciales
qui ont marqué le monde
et qui continuent aujourd'hui
de peser sur sa destinée.
Berlin.
Nous sommes en avril 1933.
Hitler est au pouvoir
depuis deux mois.
Le nouveau chef de l'Allemagne
est un antisémite obsessionnel.
Il accuse les Juifs
de dominer le monde et de l'exploiter.
Il déclare
à l'un de ses adjoints :
"L'économie est entièrement
dominée par les Juifs."
"C'est leur empire universel,"
"qu'ils ont étendu
sur tous les royaumes. "
"La lutte s'engage
entre eux et nous."
"L'enjeu est
tout simplement la destinée du monde."
Un mois plus tard,
Hitler s'en prend aux écrivains.
Il organise
des cérémonies nocturnes
où l'on brûle les livres
écrits par les communistes
et les Juifs.
Hitler a confié au responsable
de la propagande, Joseph Goebbels,
le soin de convertir
le peuple allemand à ses théories.
Hommes et femmes allemands,
l'époque du règne absolu
des intellectuels juifs touche à sa fin.
Le succès de la révolution allemande
a permis de libérer le pays.
Voici le temps
de l'homme allemand.
Dix ans plus tôt,
alors, simple militant d'extrême droite,
Goebbels a écrit dans son journal :
"Je hais le Juif
par instinct et par raison."
"Il nous empoisonne."
"Il m'est odieux
et répugnant,"
"du plus
profond de mon âme."
Au même moment
dans les environs de Berlin.
Voici les Weiler,
une petite famille juive allemande
en vacances
au bord des lacs.
Ce sont eux
les ennemis de Hitler.
Le père, Friedrich,
tient la caméra.
Il filme sa femme Hilse
et les deux petites filles
qu'ils ont eu ensemble Ella et Bärbel.
C'est un passionné d'images.
Il a donné à ses filles
un appareil de photo
pour qu'elles immortalisent
le bonheur en famille.
Dans leur maison
de campagne,
Bärbel et Ella
vivent une enfance sans nuages
comme toutes
les petites Allemandes de leur âge.
C'est le paradis.
On est tous ensemble.
Ma maman est la meilleure
maman du monde.
Et mon père,
c'est le plus fort.
C'est un ancien militaire.
Il a reçu la Croix de fer
pendant la Guerre de 14-18,
mais depuis quelques temps,
il dit qu'il veut quitter l'Allemagne.
De la fenêtre
de l'appartement familial,
la petite Ella a récemment
assisté à une parade nazie.
J'ai peur des soldats
qui défilent dans la rue.
Papa m'a expliqué
qu'ils étaient dangereux.
Ils chantent,
ils marchent au pas en bottes noires.
Rien que de les voir,
c'est horrible.
Les Weiler sont très intégrés
à la société allemande.
La petite Ella va à l'école publique,
mais elle est la seule Juive de sa classe
et depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des nazis,
elle se sent de plus en plus à part.
Les autres enfants viennent
vers moi et me disent : Juive !
Mon professeur aime les nazis.
Il a expliqué à mon père
que les Juifs n'ont pas le droit
d'avoir de très bonnes notes.
Je n'ai plus envie
d'aller en classe.
Désignés
comme ennemis public,
les Juifs sont pourtant
très peu nombreux en Allemagne.
Moins de 1%
de la population.
en France également,
où, malgré l'extrême droite,
l'un d'entre eux, Léon Blum,
s'apprête à former
un gouvernement de gauche,
le Front populaire.
En Europe de l'Ouest,
la plupart des Juifs sont
parfaitement intégrés.
Ils ont obtenu l'égalité des droits
avec les autres citoyens au XIXᵉ siècle.
Certains d'entre eux,
comme Sigmund Freud,
l'inventeur de la psychanalyse
ou le physicien Albert Einstein,
comptent parmi les grandes figures
de la culture occidentale.
Sur les 11 millions
de Juifs d'Europe,
la plupart sont ailleurs.
Ils sont à l'Est.
Regardez
ce document exceptionnel,
tourné au moment
de l'arrivée au pouvoir de Hitler.
Ce monde
a totalement disparu.
Nous sommes à Munkacs
en Tchécoslovaquie.
Ici, les Juifs représentent
presque la moitié de la population.
Ils vivent en communauté.
En exerçant
de petits métiers
et dans le culte
de leur tradition millénaire.
Une partie d'entre eux,
les juifs religieux, s'habillent avec
des vêtements hérités du XVIIIᵉ siècle.
Ils possèdent
leur propre langue : le yiddish.
Et 3 000 ans après Moïse, ils continuent
de réciter les prières des Hébreux.
Des communautés hors du temps,
loin des grands bouleversements du monde
et au centre desquels
se trouve le rabbin.
Ici,
en toque de fourrure.
Continuez à faire Shabbat
Écoutez-moi,
respectez le Shabbat et tout ira bien.
Faites les prières
On n'a pas le droit de faire moins,
c'est important
En 1933,
les Juifs de Munkacs sont loin
d'imaginer que dans à peine 15 ans,
leur communauté
aura presque entièrement été exterminée.
Cela fait pourtant des siècles
que les Juifs vivent dans la peur.
Traditionnellement en Europe,
on les tient responsable de tous
les malheurs qui touchent la population.
On leur reproche
de vivre du travail des autres.
D'être des parasites.
Et d'appartenir
à une race impure.
Surtout, les Chrétiens les jugent
responsables de la mort du Christ,
il y a 2 000 ans.
Des accusations absurdes
mais qui entretiennent la haine
et provoquent
des flambée de violence.
Des massacres
que l'on appelle pogroms,
"tonnerre"
en langue russe.
La dernière vague de pogrom
remonte à la fin de la Guerre de 14-18
quand des milliers
d'Ukrainiens nationalistes
se sont rués
à l'assaut des quartiers juifs
et ont massacré
des dizaines de milliers de personnes.
Un enquêteur,
Léo Motzkin témoigne.
Des vieillards et des enfants
ont été coupés en morceaux.
Des milliers
de femmes ont été violées.
On a mutilé des victimes
de la façon la plus atroce.
On leur coupait le bras droit
et la jambe gauche ou l'inverse.
Ici, l'état moral de la population juive
se rapproche de la démence.
En Europe de l'Est,
de plus en plus de familles juives
envisagent désormais
de partir vers l'étranger.
C'est le cas à Kaunas,
en Lituanie, de la famille Katz.
Des commerçants très intégrés,
eux aussi, à la société locale
et établis dans le pays
depuis une cinquantaine d'années.
Ce film de famille date de l'année 1929,
avant l'arrivée d'Hitler au pouvoir.
Voici les grands-parents,
Vassia et son mari Zemar.
Ils se promènent
sur les boulevards avec leur petit fils.
Zvi,
âgé de trois ans.
Deloliya et Yitzhak,
les parents,
il ne nous est resté
que cette belle photographie
de l'année
de leur mariage.
Leur fille aînée a 16 ans.
Elle s'appelle Dita.
Elle perçoit de plus en plus
d'angoisse dans sa propre famille.
J'ai entendu parler
des pogroms de Pologne et d'Ukraine.
Mon père a dit
récemment à mon grand-père :
"Prends notre argent"
"et emmène
loin d'ici toute la famille"
"car les Lituaniens vont bientôt
jeter les enfants par les fenêtres."
On nous conseille de partir,
mais,
moi, je ne veux pas.
Tout le monde
m'aime ici
et la vie est
si belle pour moi.
À 200 kilomètres de là,
la même année.
Nous sommes à Riga,
la capitale de la Lettonie.
Voici la famille Arens,
des Juifs de la bourgeoisie
comme les Katz.
Ils possèdent
une petite usine de confiserie.
Chez eux aussi,
on filme les membres de la famille
avec l'une des toutes premières
caméras personnelles.
Même sourires de façade,
même bonne humeur apparente.
Pourtant
chez les Arens,
certains ont déjà pris
la décision de quitter le pays.
C'est le cas de ce garçon de 16 ans,
qui taquine ses cousines devant la caméra.
Il s'appelle Mickaël.
Comme
le montre cette photo,
Mickaël Arens,
ici, en uniforme,
appartient
à une organisation de jeunesse.
Il fait partie
de ces militants juifs
qu'on voit
de plus en plus en Europe de l'Est
sur les places de village.
On les appelle
les sionistes.
Ils ont adopté un hymne,
la HaTikvah.
Ce qui signifie
l'espoir en hébreu.
Leur espoir,
c'est de rejoindre la Palestine
de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée
et de s'établir ici,
sur la colline de Sion,
à Jérusalem,
l'ancienne capitale des Juifs.
Le sionisme est né
au XIXᵉ siècle,
bien avant Hitler.
Pour le fondateur
du mouvement Theodor Herzl,
les Juifs seront
toujours menacés
où qu'ils se trouvent.
Qu'ils s'intègrent à la société
ou qu'ils vivent en tant que minorité
selon leur tradition.
Ils doivent donc
se constituer en nation
et fonder
leur propre patrie
où ils pourront
se défendre.
Entraînement physique,
cours d'hébreu,
avant leur départ
pour la terre de leurs ancêtres,
des milliers de jeunes juifs
sont pris en main et formés.
Ils apprennent l'agriculture
dans des fermes sionistes.
Ce sont eux,
les futurs pionniers d'Israël.
Au début
des années 1930,
c'est l'une de ces fermes
que rejoint Mickaël avec son groupe,
le Betar,
un mouvement sioniste radical.
On va dormir
sous la tente.
On chante.
On s'entraîne.
Pour nous,
c'est une nécessité de lutter
car nous avons tous
en commun l'amour de la Palestine.
Cette terre
qui fait partie de notre histoire.
Dans les années 1930,
ce sont les grandes puissances
qui se partagent le Proche-Orient.
Après
la Première Guerre mondiale,
la France s'est vue confier
le contrôle du Liban et de la Syrie.
Déjà présente
en Egypte,
la Grande-Bretagne administre
la Transjordanie et la Palestine.
En 1917,
avec la Déclaration Balfour,
la Grande-Bretagne ouvre officiellement
les portes de la Palestine aux Juifs.
Chaque année,
des milliers d'entre eux débarquent
en terre promise avec leur famille
et quelques affaires
qu'ils ont pu emporter avec eux.
Ils rejoignent
une petite communauté locale
qui n'a jamais
quitté la région
et qui n'a cessé de prier ici,
devant le mur des Lamentations.
C'est le berceau
du judaïsme.
Le dernier vestige du temple
construit il y a 2 000 ans par Hérode,
le roi des Juifs.
Le temple
a été détruit par les Romains,
il n'en reste plus,
aujourd'hui, que les murs d'enceinte.
Quelques mètres
au-dessus du mur,
les musulmans ont construit l'un
de leurs plus beaux édifices religieux.
D'après le Coran,
le prophète Mahomet a gagné le paradis
ici au VIIᵉ siècle après Jésus Christ.
C'est aussi à Jérusalem
qu'est né le christianisme.
Chaque année,
des milliers de personnes
se rendent en pèlerinage
sur les lieux
de la mort de Jésus.
C'est sur cette terre
trois fois sainte
que les sionistes comptent
mettre en œuvre leur projet.
Fonder
leur nouvelle patrie
et s'établir
définitivement.
Partout
en Palestine,
ils fondent
un nouveau type de villages agricoles,
les kibboutz.
Dans l'un d'entre eux
se trouve un jeune juif polonais,
Joël Iglinskiy.
Je n'avais
aucun avenir en Pologne.
Ici, on est une grande famille.
On se remet à l'agriculture
comme dans la Bible.
Hommes et femmes,
on travaille toute la journée
pendant que
nos enfants sont à la garderie.
Au kibboutz,
on est tous égaux,
on partage tout.
Chacun verse
son salaire à la collectivité
et on prend
toutes nos décisions en commun.
Pour ces jeunes idéalistes
venus du fin fond de l'Europe,
l'expérience est unique.
Avec ses camarades,
Joël Iglinskiy entend tout simplement
bâtir un monde différent.
On s'est engagé
à construire le socialisme.
Le drapeau rouge
flotte sur le kibboutz.
On admire Herzl,
Léon Blum et Marx.
On est
des révolutionnaires
et on sait
qu'on va changer le monde.
Sur place,
les habitants qui assistent
à l'arrivée des Juifs s'interrogent.
Que veulent
les sionistes ?
Jusqu'où ira
la colonisation des terres ?
Pourquoi
viennent-ils en Palestine ?
Dans les années 1930,
les Arabes de Palestine
sont au nombre d'un million.
Ils représentent
les deux tiers de la population
et sont répartis
sur tout le territoire
dans des centaines
de villes et de villages.
On les appelle
les Palestiniens
en souvenir du peuple
des Philistins dans l'antiquité.
Avant l'arrivée des Britanniques,
ils ont vécu sous l'empire des Turcs
pendant quatre siècles.
Regardez ces images en couleur
tournées au début du XXᵉ siècle.
Leur culture orientale
a toujours fasciné les visiteurs.
Une partie
d'entre eux sont des Bédouins.
Ils vivent dans le désert
avec leurs troupeaux,
mais la plupart
sont paysans.
Ils travaillent
pour de grands propriétaires arabes,
comme ici,
sur la plaine côtière,
où sont produites
les fameuses oranges de Jaffa.
Elles sont exportées
dans le monde entier.
Depuis déjà
plusieurs années,
quelques propriétaires arabes acceptent
de vendre leurs terres aux sionistes.
Et petit à petit,
le visage de la Palestine change.
En 1935, les Juifs représentent
déjà 30% de la population,
ils ont créé des dizaines
de villages le long de la côte et au nord.
Cela n'empêche pas
la plupart des familles arabes
de vivre
les années d'avant-guerre sans méfiance
et dans
un certain bonheur.
C'est le cas,
à Jérusalem, de la famille Saïd.
Des Arabes chrétiens,
qui possèdent une maison d'édition.
Filmé par son père
pendant les vacances d'été,
ce garçon s'appelle Edward.
C'est le futur
écrivain palestinien Edward Saïd.
Notre maison de famille
se trouvait à Talbiya,
un quartier
de Palestiniens chrétiens comme nous.
L'imposante villa de deux étages
avait de nombreuses chambres
et un joli jardin dans lequel
mes deux plus jeunes cousins,
mes sœurs
et moi pouvions jouer.
C'était
une période idyllique.
Sur leur film de famille,
rien ne laisse encore
à penser que cette période idyllique
est sur le point
de se terminer.
Au même moment,
en Allemagne.
La situation devient
dramatique pour les Juifs.
Les nazis qui cherchent
à créer un pays ethniquement pur,
multiplient
les provocations
et les inscriptions
antisémites s'étalent dans tout le pays.
Sur les tramways
et même
sur les bancs publics.
Au congrès
de Nuremberg en 1935,
les nazis excluent officiellement
les Juifs de la communauté nationale.
Chez les Juifs allemands,
la panique commence à s'installer
et de plus en plus nombreux sont
ceux qui cherchent à fuir vers l'étranger,
vers la France,
la Grande-Bretagne ou les États-Unis.
C'est là que vit déjà une communauté
juive de 4 millions de personnes.
Mais les visas pour les pays occidentaux
sont accordés au compte-goutte.
Ainsi, plus de 100 000 Juifs allemands
choisissent la Palestine
où les portes de l'immigration
leur sont encore ouvertes.
Une centaine de familles juives
arrivent en Palestine
à bord du Mariette Pacha,
de la Compagnie des Messageries Maritimes.
La plupart
sont dans un dénuement absolu,
les lois du Reich interdisant
aux Juifs le transfert de leurs biens.
Les associations sionistes
accueillent ces malheureux
et leur donnent
les moyens de refaire leur vie.
Parmi les passagers
du Mariette Pacha se trouvent les Weiler,
notre famille juive de Berlin.
Contrairement aux autres passagers,
les Weiler viennent en simples visiteurs.
Sans savoir encore
s'ils vont s'installer en Palestine
avec leurs deux petites filles
et quitter définitivement l'Allemagne.
Ils continuent de filmer
avec leur caméra personnelle.
Pour convaincre sa femme,
Friedrich Weiler lui fait visiter le pays.
Il l'emmène
sur les bords de la Mer Morte.
Ils visitent Tel-Aviv,
cette métropole juive de 130 000 habitants
sortie de terre
en moins de 20 ans.
Ils rendent visite à des amis
allemands déjà installés sur place.
Pourtant,
après une semaine de voyage,
ils hésitent encore à franchir le pas.
À Jérusalem,
ils ont trouvé
une ville en pleine ébullition,
proche de la révolte.
À l'appel
du grand mufti,
les Arabes de Palestine manifestent
contre l'occupant britannique
et sa politique favorable
à l'arrivée en masse des Juifs.
L'un de
leurs porte-paroles explique.
Depuis le début
des années 1930,
les manifestations
se succèdent en Palestine.
De plus en plus violentes.
Attaques
contre les kibboutz,
attentats
en pleine rue.
En 1936, ce qu'on appelle
la grande révolte arabe finit par éclater.
L'un de ses chefs
se nomme Fawzi al-Qawuqji.
Il lance la guérilla
contre l'armée britannique.
Nous nous révoltons
contre les injustices,
contre le sionisme,
pour défendre
notre Terre Sainte.
Les Anglais
ont abusé du sang arabe.
Aujourd'hui,
nous sommes prêts à les affronter.
La révolte s'étend
en quelques mois à toute la Palestine
et elle oblige
les Britanniques à envoyer des renforts.
La répression est implacable.
Comme ici à Jaffa où un quartier
est vidé de ses habitants et rasé.
Il faut deux ans à l'armée britannique
pour mater la révolte,
mais ce n'est
que provisoire.
En 1938,
sur l'un
des paysans arabes fait prisonniers,
on retrouve un tract,
il sonne comme un avertissement.
Aujourd'hui, vous essayez cruellement
de nous dépouiller de nos droits,
de nos maisons,
de notre honneur.
Sachez que jamais,
avant d'avoir conquis notre liberté,
nous ne rendrons les armes.
La même année,
en Allemagne.
Nous sommes
le 9 novembre 1938.
Devant la population
qui observe et parfois approuve,
les nazis incendient
les lieux de culte des Juifs.
C'est la Nuit de cristal.
Un gigantesque pogrom au cours duquel
8 000 boutiques sont saccagées
et une centaine
de Juifs assassinés.
Quelques mois plus tôt,
l'Allemagne a pris le contrôle
de l'Autriche où vivent 200 000 Juifs.
Dans un nouveau
déchaînement d'antisémitisme,
la tension augmente
brusquement en Europe
et le risque d'une nouvelle guerre
mondiale se rapproche.
Certains Juifs d'Europe
réalisent que pour eux,
le compte à rebours
a commencé.
Peu avant la Nuit de cristal,
les Weiler ont pris la décision
de quitter définitivement Berlin
et d'émigrer en Palestine.
Sur les photos prises avant le départ,
les parents tentent de faire bonne figure,
mais Friedrich note
dans son journal :
"Nous passons les derniers jours
dans la peur."
"Jusqu'au bout
j'ai craint que la Gestapo"
"nous réclame
une formalité supplémentaire."
"La dernière nuit, ma mère
a cru suffoquer à l'idée de notre départ."
La mère de Friedrich, Ida,
a décidé de rester en Allemagne.
Elle tente de rassurer
ses petites filles.
Les nazis,
il ne faut aut pas s'inquiéter.
On les a juste
pour un moment.
Tout ça, vous verrez,
ça passera.
Berlin,
le jour du départ.
Les parents
prennent d'ultimes photos sur le quai.
La grand-mère, Ida, est venue
dire au revoir à toute la famille.
Ella, sa petite fille,
ici à droite, est enthousiaste.
Elle ne réalise pas qu'elle voit
sa grand-mère pour la dernière fois.
Je suis excitée
par ce voyage.
C'est une nouvelle vie
qui commence.
On traverse l'Autriche
où Hitler vient de prendre le pouvoir.
On passe les Alpes.
C'est la première fois
que je vois de si grandes montagnes.
Et puis ça y est,
on se retrouve en Italie.
Les nazis,
avec leur méchanceté, sont derrière nous.
La famille a embarqué
en direction de la Palestine.
Notre bateau
s'appelle le Jérusalem.
Pour passer le temps,
maman fait du tricot
et moi,
je lis des livres toute la journée.
Après cinq jours de mer,
les Weiler débarquent en Palestine.
Les parents ont choisi de s'installer
dans une petite maison au nord de Tel-Aviv
où ils pensent que leurs deux filles
pourront grandir en sécurité.
Ils apprendront bientôt
qu'ils sont parmi les derniers
à avoir pu
rejoindre la Palestine.
Car au printemps 1939,
la situation
bascule brusquement.
La Grande-Bretagne,
qui occupe toujours la Palestine,
prend une décision
qui remet tout en cause.
Pour se ménager le soutien des Arabes
dans la prochaine guerre contre Hitler,
les Britanniques décident
de cesser de soutenir le sionisme.
De limiter le nombre
des visas d'entrée aux Juifs
ainsi que les achats de terres.
Une décision
catastrophique pour les sionistes
qui comptaient faire émigrer
des millions de Juifs d'Europe
avant
le déclenchement de la guerre.
Leur chef en Palestine,
David Ben Gourion,
choisit à son tour de passer en force.
Il décide d'accélérer
les opérations tours et palissades,
ces créations de colonies
qui se sont multipliées
les années précédentes
et qui misent
sur l'effet de surprise.
Nous sommes le 12 juillet 1939,
à Negba, près du désert du Néguev.
Les militants sionistes
ont chargé sur un convoi
des maisons préfabriquée
qu'ils vont installer ici.
Sur ces terrains
qu'ils ont auparavant achetés aux Arabes.
Parmi eux
se trouve Joël Iglinskiy.
"Il faut aller vite."
"Chacun sait ce qu'il doit faire."
"On dresse des palissades en mettant
du gravier à l'intérieur des planches"
"pour arrêter les balles."
"On monte
la tour de guet."
"On oublie la fatigue"
"car nous sommes
les soldats de la révolution sioniste"
"et on sait qu'on fait quelque chose
de plus grand que nous."
À l'été 1939,
à l'approche du cataclysme qui se prépare,
les Juifs retiennent leur souffle.
Certains,
comme nous l'avons montré,
ont cherché un refuge
en émigrant en Palestine.
D'autres espèrent encore continuer
à vivre en Europe malgré le danger.
Il ne leur faudra que quelques mois
pour réaliser l'inimaginable.
Le projet de destruction
de tout un peuple par les nazis.
C'est ce nouveau chapitre
que nous allons maintenant vous raconter.
1ᵉʳ septembre 1939,
l'Allemagne
envahit la Pologne.
C'est le début
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Dès les premières semaines,
les nazis, qui écrasent l'armée polonaise,
multiplient les exactions.
Travail forcé,
coups,
humiliations,
comme le montrent des dizaines
de photos prises dans tout le pays,
les soldats allemands
se déchaînent contre les Juifs.
Hitler a ordonné
de regrouper les Juifs polonais,
hommes, femmes et enfants,
dans des quartiers qui leur sont réservés,
les ghettos.
Les nazis ont choisi d'isoler
leurs futures victimes du reste du monde,
de les affamer peu à peu,
avant, bientôt, de décider
de les assassiner en masse, ici.
Le massacre commence
un an et demi plus tard,
le 22 juin 1941,
quand l'armée allemande
attaque l'URSS.
Une offensive foudroyante qui,
en quelques jours,
repousse les Soviétiques
sur des centaines de kilomètres.
Dans les villes conquises,
les nazis lancent immédiatement
les persécutions contre les Juifs
en se faisant aider
par la population.
Partout, comme ici à Zloczow,
des nationalistes
pro-allemands,
des militants d'extrême droite
et des repris de justice
lancent des pogroms
sous les encouragements des Allemands.
Ils accusent les Juifs
d'être responsables de massacres
qui ont été commis par les Soviétiques
quelques jours plus tôt.
À Lvov,
en Ukraine,
un soldat allemand filme la foule
et les miliciens ukrainiens.
Des dizaines
de femmes juives,
après avoir été violées,
vont être assassinées avec leur famille.
Un sergent SS, Félix Landau,
pourtant farouchement antisémite,
est surpris
par ce déchaînement de violence.
"Nous voyons des choses
presque impossibles à décrire."
"Des centaines
de Juifs couverts de sang,"
"des trous dans la tête,"
"les mains brisées"
"et les yeux pendant
hors de leurs orbites"
"se font frapper"
"de haine"
"et de rage."
En quelques heures, le massacre
s'étend à des dizaines de villes.
Le 4 juillet toujours,
les Allemands
approchent de Kaunas en Lituanie.
C'est ici que vit Dita Katz
et toute sa famille.
Vous vous rappelez de ce film
tourné douze ans plus tôt, en 1929 ?
À l'arrivée des Allemands, le grand-père
tente de rassurer sa famille.
"N'ayez pas peur
des Allemands."
"Je les ai connus
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale."
"Ce sont des gens civilisés."
Pourtant,
dès les premières heures,
son propre fils Itzhak,
disparaît au coin d'une rue.
La suite,
c'est un caporal allemand qui la raconte.
"Des Lituaniens
avec des bâtons et des pieds de biche,"
"frappent
les Juifs au sol,"
"sur le crâne
ou sur le visage."
"Sans distinction,
ils reçoivent des coups"
"jusqu'à ce qu'ils ne montrent plus
aucun signe de vie."
"En trois quarts d'heure,"
"celui qu'on présente
comme le bourreau de la ville"
"a tué
une cinquantaine de personnes."
"Tout autour,
les Allemands regardent le spectacle."
En Bavière,
de son chalet de montagne,
Hitler approuve les pogroms.
Mais il veut les encadrer
et les rationnaliser.
Il a chargé Heinrich Himmler,
le chef des SS, ici à gauche,
de monter des unités spéciales :
les Einsatzgruppen.
Leur mission est de supprimer
en quelques mois
toute trace du peuple Juif
sur les territoires conquis.
Les Einsatzgruppen fusilleront les Juifs
directement dans des fosses communes.
À Libau,
non loin de Kaunas,
le soldat
de la marine allemande,
Reinhardt Wiener,
filme avec sa caméra personnelle
l'un de ces massacres.
Un camion arrive.
Les gardes forcent
les Juifs à sauter à terre.
Il y a parmi eux
des hommes faibles et des malades,
ils s'entraident mutuellement.
Ils sont poussés
vers la tranchée par un SS.
Quand ils arrivent
dans la tranchée,
ils doivent marcher
sur les corps recouverts de sable,
le peloton d'exécution
se tient devant eux,
on leur demande
de se retourner
en attendant
que le groupe suivant arrive.
L'ampleur du massacre
est sans équivalent dans l'Histoire.
En six mois, les Einsatzgruppen
assassinent un demi million de Juifs.
Devant ses troupes,
Himmler donne la consigne.
"Que faire
des femmes et des enfants ?"
"Je pense qu'on ne peut pas
exterminer les hommes"
"et en même temps
laisser leurs enfants devenir adultes"
"pour qu'ils se vengent plus tard
sur nos enfants et nos petits-enfants."
À la fin de l'année 1941,
les informations
sur le génocide commencent à filtrer.
En Palestine, la population arabe
reste à l'écart du conflit.
Même si son chef spirituel,
le grand mufti de Jérusalem,
exilé par les Britanniques,
a choisi de collaborer avec Hitler.
Il a levé un régiment
de musulmans bosniaques pro-nazis.
Les Juifs,
eux, s'alarment
de ne plus recevoir
de nouvelles de leurs proches.
C'est le cas de Mickaël Arens,
le jeune sioniste de Riga,
qui est arrivé en Palestine en 1938
et qui s'est enrôlé
dans la police.
Il ignore que sa mère,
restée en Lettonie,
a été tuée dès les premiers jours
de l'offensive allemande.
Friedrich Weiler, lui non plus,
ne peut plus communiquer avec sa mère,
Ida,
restée à Berlin.
Le 2 novembre 1941,
il écrit dans son journal.
"Nouvelles horribles
en provenance d'Allemagne."
"Les Juifs qui sont là-bas
sont déportés de leur maison"
"et envoyés
comme du bétail vers la Pologne."
"Ces nouvelles sont si inhumaines
qu'on a du mal à les croire."
"On leur demande de creuser
et ils sont massacrés dans ces tombes."
En novembre 1941,
Ida Weiler, la grand-mère,
a déjà été déportée à l'est.
Elle se trouve ici
à Lodz, en Pologne,
avec 140 000 autres Juifs.
Tous ceux
qui ont échappé aux premiers pogroms
sont désormais
enfermés dans les ghettos.
C'est le cas,
à Kaunas, de Dita Katz.
Avec sa mère
et son petit frère Zvi,
avec son fiancé Yéhouda,
Dita ne nourrit plus
aucune illusion sur son sort.
"Je sais
depuis la disparition de mon père"
"que les nazis
sont en train de nous exterminer."
"Ce qui arrive
est inimaginable"
"et personne
ne nous aide."
À la fin de l'année 1941,
les nazis, qui occupent
presque toute l'Europe,
lancent
la solution finale.
C'est
la deuxième phase de la Shoah.
De partout, en France
avec l'aide du régime de Vichy.
En Roumanie,
en Yougoslavie,
en Pologne,
les Juifs sont regroupés
puis dirigés
dans la panique
vers
des destinations inconnues.
C'est de Hollande,
au camp de transit de Westerbork,
que nous est resté le témoignage le
plus précis de la déportation des juifs.
Ces images ont été prises
par des soldats allemands.
Ce sont des documents uniques.
Chaque matin, un train embarque plusieurs
milliers de personnes vers l'Est.
Une infirmière juive,
Etty Hillesum, assiste au départ.
"Les bétaillères
se remplissent peu à peu."
"Je vois transporter une personne âgée
au dernier stade de la maladie"
"et qui dit
la prière des morts."
"Les bébés avec leurs petits cris perçants
qu'on a arrachés à leur berceau."
"Des jeunes femmes
sont déjà assises dans le wagon."
"Ces portes
vont-elles vraiment se fermer ?"
"Hélas, oui."
"Les minces ouvertures
laissent encore entrevoir des visages."
"Pourra-t-on un jour
décrire au monde extérieur"
"ce qu'il s'est passé ici ?"
Pour que le monde réalise
la tragédie qui a touché le peuple Juif,
il faudra attendre
encore deux ans.
Printemps 1945,
la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Après cinq ans
de cauchemars,
l'Europe fête la victoire
contre le régime nazi.
L'un des pires
que le monde ait connu.
Durant l'hiver,
les soldats alliés et soviétiques
ont libéré des dizaines
de camps d'extermination et de travail.
Majdanek,
Auschwitz,
Bergen-Belsen.
Et le monde a appris
comment la majorité des victimes ont péri.
Dans des chambres à gaz
et des fours crématoires
qui brûlent parfois encore
lorsque les camps sont libérés.
Le bilan est
de 5 millions de victimes juives,
6 millions,
apprend-t-on un peu plus tard.
Comment le monde
a-t-il laissé commettre ce génocide ?
À une réunion
du Congrès juif mondial,
l'un des responsables
du mouvement sioniste,
Nahum Goldmann,
laisse éclater sa colère.
Le port de Haïfa, en Palestine,
quelques mois après la fin de la guerre.
Sur des bateaux de fortune
parfois sur le point de sombrer,
les premiers rescapés des camps
rejoignent la Terre Sainte.
Sur l'un de ces bateaux
se trouve un Juif polonais,
Garcher Rabinovitch.
"De là où je suis,
la Palestine m'apparaît comme un paradis."
"C'est la première lumière
que je vois depuis 17 ans."
"J'en pleure de joie."
"Vous savez ce que ça fait
d'être accueilli quelque part"
"après avoir été haï"
"et chassé
de pays en pays ?"
Soulagement pour les uns,
mais inquiétude pour les autres.
Devant l'arrivée
des rescapés juifs d'Europe,
de nouveau,
les Arabes de Palestine protestent.
À Jaffa, un adolescent,
Youssef Chaker, pose la question.
"Les Juifs ont horriblement souffert
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale."
"Mais nous les Arabes,
on n'y est pour rien."
"Pourquoi on devrait
subir les conséquences"
"du génocide nazi
contre les Juifs ?"
"Pourquoi ils ne vont pas
créer leur État en Europe,"
"là où ils ont été massacrés,
au lieu de venir chez nous ?"
Pour dissuader
toute nouvelle révolte arabe,
la Grande-Bretagne continue
d'appliquer sa politique d'avant-guerre.
Elle interdit aux Juifs
de se rendre en Palestine,
mais cette fois, elle fait arrêter
tous les immigrants sans papiers
et les regroupe
dans des camps.
Après les camps
de la mort nazis,
les rescapés de la Shoah connaissent
les camps de prisonniers britanniques.
Ils ne vont
pas tarder à réagir.
En Europe, 150 000 rescapés juifs
attendent près des anciens camps nazis,
comme ici,
en Autriche.
Ils hésitent
à retourner en Pologne ou en Russie
où ils craignent de retrouver
l'antisémitisme qu'ils ont toujours connu.
Parmi eux
se trouve Dita Katz,
qui a miraculeusement
survécu aux camps de la mort.
Malgré la mort de son père en 1941
et celle de son mari en 1944,
Dita choisit de revenir
dans sa ville natale.
En Lituanie où elle espère
retrouver ses amis d'avant-guerre
et refaire sa vie.
Son petit frère Zvi,
le garçon filmé en 1929,
a maintenant 18 ans.
Lui aussi a survécu à la Shoah,
mais il fait un choix différent.
Avec sa mère,
ils décident de se rendre en Palestine.
Pour contourner
l'interdiction britannique,
il a pris contact
avec une filière clandestine
et ce sont des agents sionistes
qui vont le faire traverser toute l'Europe
sans papiers d'identité
et sans visa.
En 1947, l'un de ces voyages est filmé
par le journaliste américain Meyer Levin.
En train, puis en camion,
Zvi et sa mère traversent la Pologne,
la Tchécoslovaquie,
l'Allemagne, l'Autriche.
Après plusieurs
semaines de voyage,
ils sont déposés au pied des Alpes
avec un groupe de réfugiés
et c'est à pieds qu'ils vont passer
illégalement la frontière italienne.
"Il y a avec nous
des femmes et des enfants."
"Mais rien ne pourra
nous empêcher de rejoindre la Palestine."
"Nous sommes
à 2 700 mètres d'altitude,"
"maman ne faiblit pas."
"On se sent
sûrs de nous"
"car on sait qu'on va enfin
avoir un pays, comme tout le monde."
De l'autre côté de la frontière,
ils embarquent dans la région de Rome
de nuit,
sur un navire clandestin.
C'est d'ici que par dizaines, des navires
emmènent les Juifs vers la Palestine
pour les débarquer
sur une plage déserte.
Des voyages
à haut risque.
L'un de ces bateaux,
l'Exodus, a été récemment arraisonné
par la flotte britannique.
L'abordage a fait
plusieurs morts et blessés
et l'Exodus
a été renvoyé vers l'Allemagne.
Cette fois-ci, les sionistes
veulent prendre toutes les précautions.
Dès qu'un navire est en vue,
les 950 passagers illégaux
reçoivent l'ordre d'évacuer le pont
et ils se réfugient
dans les cales.
Le journaliste
Meyer Levin continue de filmer
tandis que sa compagne,
Tereska Torrès, tient un journal de bord.
"Ce bateau est un radeau
de la méduse moderne."
"Il n'y a presque pas d'air, ni lumière,
seulement une odeur irrespirable."
"Les femmes,
souvent hystériques, s'évanouissent."
"Vers 1h du matin
est né un petit garçon."
"La mère a crié à tue-tête
pendant deux heures."
Après 12 jours de navigation,
alors que le navire touche au but,
un avion
survole les clandestins.
Il est suivi
par un navire de guerre britannique
qui s'approche
et ordonne de stopper les machines.
Démasqués,
les passagers sortent au grand jour.
Pour eux, comme le note
Tereska Torrès dans son journal,
le rêve s'arrête quand les soldats anglais
prennent le contrôle du navire.
"Nous vivons
les dernières heures du bateau."
"À mesure
que nous approchons de Haïfa,"
"la ville se lève
devant nous,"
"si belle et interdite
à ces pauvres gens."
"Une compagnie de soldats armés
et casqués nous attend sur le quai."
Les passagers sont tous dirigés
vers des camps de prisonniers
que les Britanniques
ont établis sur l'île de Chypre.
C'est là, enfermés
derrière de nouveaux barbelés,
que Zvi Katz et sa mère
vont passer plusieurs mois.
Pour eux et pour les militants sionistes,
la situation est devenue insupportable.
En Palestine, des groupes armés juifs
décident de passer à l'action
et de lancer
une campagne de terreur.
Des attentats
d'une extrême violence
qui visent à faire plier les Anglais
et à les chasser de Palestine.
À la radio clandestine,
une terroriste de 18 ans,
Gueoulah Cohen, menace.
"Vous, les Britanniques,"
"vous allez payer pour
chaque larme de juif qui tend les mains"
"et auquel
vous refusez le secours."
"L'enfer va entrer
dans vos vies"
"et la terreur inondera
chaque parcelle de votre corps."
"Car nous avons prêté serment
de libérer la terre d'Israël."
En Palestine, les attentats arabes
répondent désormais aux attentats juifs.
Et la région est une nouvelle fois
au bord de l'explosion.
C'est alors que parvient
de New York une nouvelle qui change tout.
Nous sommes le 29 novembre 1947,
au siège des Nations Unies.
Ce jour-là doit se tenir
une assemblée générale extraordinaire.
L'une de celles
qui vont marquer l'Histoire.
Commission d'enquête,
audition publique,
discours.
Depuis un an, la communauté internationale
étudie une solution pour le Proche-Orient
et elle s'apprête à voter sur le partage
territorial de la Palestine.
En vert, les territoires
proposés aux Arabes,
en bleu,
ceux qui sont proposés aux Juifs.
Au milieu,
la région de Jérusalem,
qui serait administrée
par la communauté internationale.
Les sionistes
ont accepté le partage,
mais les pays arabes
ont tous annoncé qu'ils voteraient contre.
Pour être adopté, le projet doit
recueillir les deux tiers des voix.
Miné par la culpabilité
à l'égard du peuple juif,
les États-Unis ont annoncé
qu'ils voteraient pour
et la Grande-Bretagne
qu'elle s'abstiendrait.
Le suspens
porte sur deux pays.
Tenté jusqu'au bout
par l'abstention,
la France vient de donner
un coup de pouce aux sionistes.
Elle est suivie par l'Union Soviétique.
C'est inattendu,
mais les grandes puissances
font basculer le vote.
En quelques minutes,
la cause des sionistes
vient de progresser
comme jamais auparavant.
Dans la foule de Tel-Aviv qui explose
de joie à l'annonce de la nouvelle,
se trouve la jeune
berlinoise Bärbel Weiler.
"Notre rêve est
en train de devenir réalité."
"L'État juif
se rapproche de nous."
"C'est fantastique."
"On danse,
on rit, on chante."
"Tout le monde
s'embrasse sans se connaître."
"Quelle joie !"
Ils ont franchi
les frontières clandestinement,
rejoint leur terre
promise sur des navires de fortune,
ils disposent maintenant du soutien
de la communauté internationale.
À la fin de l'année 1947,
les sionistes semblent près du but.
Les deux peuples vont-ils
maintenant réussir à s'entendre ?
Selon l'ONU,
le partage
doit être suivi de deux États séparés,
l'un juif,
l'autre arabe.
Nous allons
vous expliquer
pourquoi ce projet
s'est effondré en seulement six mois
et comment la création d'Israël a plongé
les Arabes de Palestine dans le malheur
et l'exil
pour des dizaines d'années.
30 novembre 1947,
au lendemain du vote de l'ONU.
Une jeune Arabe de Jaffa,
Afif Elkouri, est révoltée.
"Pourquoi devrait-on donner
la moitié du pays ?"
"Pour qu'ils en fassent
un État juif ?"
"Et que vont devenir
les non-juifs ?"
"Maintenant,
il n'y a plus qu'une solution, se battre."
Pour défendre leurs droits,
des milliers de paysans
s'engagent dans la guérilla.
L'un de leurs chefs
est Fawzi al-Qawuqji.
L'un des héros
de la grande révolte arabe de 1936.
Il n'a que quelques semaines
pour entraîner ses troupes.
"Mes soldats n'ont que des armes sommaires
qu'ils ont achetées eux-mêmes."
"On a envoyé des SOS
aux pays arabes voisins, en vain."
"Pourtant, la haine est si intense
qu'on est prêt à se sacrifier."
Dans le camp d'en face,
la Haganah, la future armée d'Israël
s'entraîne depuis des mois.
Encadrée de vétérans
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
elle est composée
de jeunes recrues très motivées.
Parmi eux, Zvi Katz,
ici, à droite de la photo.
Il s'est échappé du camp de Chypre
grâce à un réseau clandestin.
"Je ne pense
qu'à me battre."
"Pour nous,
c'est une question de dignité."
"On ne veut plus être comme des
animaux qui se font tuer sans rien dire."
"Plus jamais on ne se laissera
massacrer comme des moutons."
Les deux jeunes berlinoises,
Ella et Bärbel Weiler,
se sont, elles aussi,
engagées dans la Haganah.
Elles viennent d'apprendre
que leur grand-mère est morte
pendant la guerre en Pologne,
assassinée par les nazis
Elles sont déterminées.
"Pendant la guerre,
personne n'a agi pour sauver les Juifs."
"Aujourd'hui,
on ne peut plus compter que sur nous."
"Si on ne s'aide pas nous-mêmes,
qui nous aidera ?"
Au printemps 1948,
Fawzi al-Qawuqji
et les autres chefs arabes
lancent leurs troupes
à l'assaut des positions juives.
L'une des cibles
est le kibboutz de Mishmar-Haémek,
le point de passage
de la Galilée vers Tel-Aviv.
"On attaque à 5h du matin,
le jour du shabbat chez les Juifs."
"Je donne l'ordre
de tirer au canon"
"pour détruire
le plus grand nombre de maisons possible."
"Ils ont l'air
d'avoir beaucoup de pertes."
En face, les défenseurs du kibboutz
répondent coup pour coup.
L'un d'entre eux,
Joël Lotan, filme les combats.
"On essaie
de repousser l'ennemi."
"Et on espère tenir
jusqu'à l'arrivée des renforts."
"Heureusement,
au bout de quelques jours,"
"des soldats de la Haganah finissent
par nous rejoindre par les collines,"
"en provenance d'Haïfa."
En quelques jours,
la Palestine s'embrase.
Offensive,
contre-offensive,
la Haganah,
mieux organisée que l'armée arabe,
parvient à prendre le dessus
dès les premières semaines
et à faire
des milliers de prisonniers.
Dans les villes conquises,
la population prend peur
et envisage
de fuir les combats.
Le 9 avril 1948,
un événement renforce ces craintes.
À Deir Yassin, des extrémistes juifs
massacrent près de 200 villageois arabes,
dont des enfants.
Un carnage
dont il ne reste aucune image,
mais dont la nouvelle
fait le tour du monde
et déclenche la panique.
À Jaffa,
quelques rares photos prises sur le vif
montrent les habitants
qui abandonnent leur maison
et quittent la ville.
Parmi eux
se trouve Youssef Chaker.
"On a entendu parler
de Deir Yassin à la radio."
"On a entendu que les pays arabes
allaient venir nous secourir."
"En attendant,
on préfère partir."
"Je monte dans un camion, on s'entasse
et on prend la direction de Beyrouth."
C'est le début
de l'exode palestinien.
À quelques rues
de là se trouvent Afif Elkouri.
"Toute la ville est
en train de fuir."
"À la radio arabe, on nous dit
qu'on va revenir dans deux semaines,"
"mais
est-ce que c'est bien sûr ? "
Ceux qui ont fui ne seront jamais
autorisés à rentrer chez eux.
Désormais, la ville de Jaffa,
désertée de ses habitants,
sera considérée officiellement
comme une ville israélienne.
14 mai 1948,
le jour où tout bascule.
Il est 10h du matin
sur le port de Haïfa.
Le gouverneur britannique Alan Cunningham,
embarque en direction de l'Angleterre.
La Grande-Bretagne met fin
à trois décennies de présence en Palestine
et laisse
les deux camps face à face.
Six heures plus tard, à Tel-Aviv,
le chef des sionistes, David Ben Gourion,
décide de proclamer l'État juif.
Après
des années de lutte,
les sionistes
renouent avec l'histoire juive.
Derrière leur drapeau va se ranger
une minorité des Arabes de Palestine.
150 000 personnes
qui choisissent de rester sur place
et qui deviendront citoyens israéliens.
Ils représentent aujourd'hui,
60 ans plus tard, 20 % de la population.
Mais la plupart
des Arabes de Palestine prennent la route.
C'est presque
tout un peuple,
hommes, femmes et enfants,
qui fuient maintenant vers l'étranger.
On l'appelle la Nakba,
la catastrophe en langue arabe.
L'exode qui a commencé en avril
après le massacre de Deir Yassin,
va toucher
plus de 700 000 personnes.
Les deux tiers
de la population arabe.
L'entrée en guerre
contre Israël de sept pays arabes
au lendemain
du discours de Ben Gourion,
ne change rien
à leur sort.
Après plusieurs semaines de bataille et
la prise de la vielle ville de Jérusalem,
après plusieurs
avancées spectaculaires,
les armées arabes battent en retraite
et perdent de nouveaux territoires.
Une situation qui renforce encore
le flot de réfugiés palestiniens.
Selon les dernières recherches historiques
menées en Israël,
la moitié
aurait été expulsée de force
par les soldats israéliens.
Ils ont trouvé refuge
dans les pays arabes voisins,
en Jordanie ou au Liban,
dans des camps de réfugiés.
Parmi eux
se trouve Abu Hicham, 19 ans.
"On nous a donné des tentes."
"Le sol est trempé."
"On n'a plus de pays."
"On ne peut plus
vivre normalement."
"On nous distribue
du pain et du fromage."
"Je me sens humilié
et je ne pense qu'à une chose,"
"revenir dans mon village."
"Aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra,
nous nous battrons."
Haine,
humiliation,
exil.
En 1948,
l'histoire
du conflit israélo-arabe
ne fait
que commencer.
Aujourd'hui, Abu Hicham, 78 ans,
a toujours le statut de réfugié.
Il vit dans un camp palestinien
de la banlieue de Beyrouth, au Liban,
à quelques kilomètres
d'Afif Elkouri.
Depuis 60 ans,
ni l'un ni l'autre n'ont été autorisés
à revenir vivre sur leur terre natale,
la Palestine.
Certains ont émigré en Occident,
comme Edward Saïd,
le petit Arabe chrétien de Jérusalem.
Devenu professeur d'université
à New York,
Edward Saïd a été l'un des plus célèbres
porte-parole du peuple palestinien
jusqu'à sa mort en 2003.
En face, en Israël,
tous ont tenté de refaire leur vie
malgré le traumatisme
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Mickaël Arens, le jeune sioniste de Riga,
s'est consacré à l'agriculture en Galilée.
Très marquée
par ses souvenirs d'enfance,
la berlinoise Ella Weiler s'est mariée
avec un juif venu d'Allemagne comme elle.
Ils ont eu
deux enfants.
Sa sœur, Bärbel,
s'est mariée avec un rescapé d'Auschwitz
d'origine polonaise.
Elle vit avec lui
à Tel-Aviv.
Reconnaissante à son père,
mort dans les années 1960,
de lui avoir fait quitter l'Allemagne
quand il était encore temps.
Ce n'est qu'en 1972 que Dita Katz
a quitté la Lituanie pour Israël.
Elle y a retrouvé son frère Zvi,
devenu officier de réserve.
Ils vivent à Tel-Aviv
dans le souvenir de leurs proches
assassinés par les nazis.
Le plus étonnant est peut
être Joël Iglinskiy.
À 99 ans,
il habite toujours à Nekbah,
le kibboutz
qu'il a créé en 1939.
Plus que jamais, il reste fidèle
à l'idéal socialiste de sa jeunesse.